i'm gonna be honest it's hard to open an
internet browser and not feel like a
helpless passenger on the hot mess
express
even before kovid issues like climate
change
human rights violations systemic racism
and corporate abuse have left
many of us feeling cynical and helpless
and if you've taken a look at your
investment portfolio
you almost can't help but ask are my
investments making these problems
even worse it's a fair question on one
hand
the whole purpose of investing is to
grow your money
on the other the cost of those profits
might be quite steep
on both society and the planet so
do you continue to take part in this
system no matter the cost
or is there a better way can you really
make an impact with the way you invest
[Music]
thank you to morningbrew for supporting
pbs from wall street to silicon valley
and
everywhere in between morning brew is a
news source aggregated and curated
from major news outlets so that you can
get up to speed in a few minutes
morning brew news covers topics like
business finance and tech
on morning brew i learned that digital
black friday sales increased over
20 percent this year to 9 billion
and while it was no surprise that far
fewer people are shopping at brick and
mortar stores this year
i learned that u.s store visits dropped
over 50 percent from last year
reading the morning brew newsletter i
also learned about major mergers and
acquisitions over the past year
including market indices across the
globe buying large
data providers which underscores the
rising prominence
of data analytics across the world of
finance
i could sign up in a few seconds and i
can read the daily newsletter in a few
minutes
for more information you can visit the
link in the description to sign up for
morning brew
the bedrock of capitalism is the
motivation to make
a profit but there's always been some
fringe group that felt there was more to
consider
all the way back to the late 1700s
colonial america
subsets of protestantism like the
methodists and quakers
let their moral and religious beliefs
guide their investments
to them industries around slavery
alcohol and tobacco were immoral
and they actively avoided investing any
money in them
and there you have it the concept of
impact investing was born in america
for centuries socially responsible
investments or
sris as they came to be called were
synonymous with religious and moral
values
but in the 21st century the concept of
impact investing began to
fundamentally change with a new acronym
esg
first coined in 2004 by a u.n commission
report titled who cares wins
esg stands for environmental social and
governance criteria
that can help an investor assess the
financial strength of an investment in
the modern world
that is to say more than just being
wrong or right
in a moral sense choosing companies that
score highly on esg
criteria results in a better investment
for society the planet and your
pocketbook
over the past decade major ratings
agencies began
assigning numerical esg scores to etfs
mutual funds
even individual companies and while
there's currently no
single uniform rating standard by
looking at the scores of several
agencies and
understanding how they calculate their
scores you can gauge the relative impact
of your investment so what might have a
positive or negative impact on an esg
score well the e focuses on factors
like natural resource use pollution and
sustainability initiatives
companies that make positive steps to
reduce their carbon footprint or
utilize greater renewable energy
resources will benefit from a higher
e-score
the social aspect refers to corporate
behaviors that impact the public
for instance in 2019 when walmart
decided to stop
selling certain types of ammunition in
response to recent gun violence
surveys found that people were more
likely to shop there
shortly after the decision not to
mention giving a small boost
to their escort and governance is a
measure of the ethics
and transparency of a company's leaders
the
doctoring of volkswagen's emissions
tests and wells fargo's fraudulent
account openings
damaged the public trust and damaged
their g-scores
how much of an impact can this approach
actually make
take an example from the 1960s and 70s
american university students and
teachers had begun
protesting apartheid in south africa but
momentum
really began to build when they
pressured their schools to completely
stop investing their endowments in south
africa
this is known as protest divestment and
was a radical move when you consider
that between
a third and a half of the s p 500 did
business in south africa
this culminated in 1986 when congress
banned
any new u.s investment in the country
resulting in a
billion dollar loss in capital for south
africa the economic fallout
coupled with the decades of political
resistance finally led to the end of
apartheid in the early 90s
today more and more companies are
beginning to take the esg movement
seriously one study found that a third
of american companies
say esg ratings are shaping their
overall business strategy
larry fink the ceo of the world's
largest investment firm blackrock
wrote in his annual letter that every
company must not
only deliver financial performance but
also
show how it makes a positive
contribution to society
and at the world economic forum in davos
this year major financial institutions
made a big
show of removing carbon heavy
investments from their portfolios
but let's talk hard numbers here does
investing with your conscience
hurt your returns not necessarily
a recent morgan stanley study compared
returns for over 10
000 funds between 2004 and 2018.
the study found there was no financial
trade-off at all between
impact-focused funds and their
traditional counterparts
furthermore these funds seem to offer
even lower risk
especially during turbulent times like
this past year
this might be because sustainable
practices make companies
less vulnerable to things like ethics
scandals or a massive oil spill
simply put focusing on esg is good
business for the long term
and while impact-oriented funds have
long been derided as more expensive than
their counterparts
their recent rise in popularity has
driven major fund companies to enter
into a price war
to offer the cheapest esg funds
blackrock and vanguard have esg funds as
cheap as two dollars per year for every
thousand dollars invested
while still slightly more expensive than
a pure index fund
due to the need for esg analysis the
difference
seems to shrink with every passing year
so how do you get started
if you're a diy-er you can make your own
custom tailored portfolio of positive
impact stocks based on their esg ratings
online tools like sustainalytics allow
you to compare esg ratings for
any publicly traded stock there are also
hundreds of esg mutual funds
and etfs some are broad in scope like
vanguard's esg us stock etf
while others have a focus that is made
obvious in their ticker or name
for example there's the ssga gender
diversity etf that favors a high
proportion of women in executive
positions or the ishares
low carbon target etf that focuses on
companies
with a small carbon footprint the year
2020 left
a lot of people sick of the status quo
longing for a change and in 2020 esg
funds
also saw record-breaking inflows from
investors
wanting to build a better tomorrow so
the question is
will you be casting a vote and that's
our two cents
hey everybody hello so we're here at the
end of the video to address some
comments and questions
from our last video about how your cell
phone is ripping you off
i actually learned a lot just looking
through the comments of
how different data is priced in
different countries
we have a huge amount of people who i
know watch us in india
big shout out uh and your data plans are
really cheap and i'm jealous
so let's start with brent he said i know
friends that have unlimited data
just so they can stream spotify premium
on the road just download your music to
your phone
and listen to playlists or the radio or
podcasts and netflix allows you to
download on wi-fi
and watch later without streaming i
honestly forget
about the ability to download all the
time
a little bit of planning can make it so
you don't really need unlimited data
but also if you do some planning about
how you use that data
of downloading videos or downloading
music
it can really be doable dan said i was
expecting a talk on how we buy
expensive phones with features most of
us don't use
only to keep them a limited amount of
time
or how much time we lose with phones
this is really touching on the
behavioral
financial aspect of this i know a lot of
us are really really guilty of doing
that right if it's like
maybe once i buy that then i'll use this
super expensive feature on this phone or
all of this storage
and it's just sort of an emotional
decision but i think talking about how
much we're spending on the phone itself
is
a great suggestion to look at for a
future episode thank you
finally i wanted to highlight what
nicholas shepard wrote he said
one place i cannot recommend highly
enough for viewing different plans
is whistle out which is a website that
compares many different data plans from
different
providers based on what you need so i
did a little bit of digging on this i
had never heard of this so thank you
so it seems like it's pretty legit let
me know if you've used it
in the past after we made this video i
was like
we've got to do this on ourselves
because legit we spend
way too much and i just never think to
challenge it it's just one of those ones
where i'm like
well i guess i just need this because
we're on our phones
all the time we're committed we're gonna
do it and we will see you
next time see ya bye before you go you
should check out tara
a new channel from pbs digital studios
with a bunch of great science shows
you can travel to antarctica fly with
drones and get a glimpse
inside of a wildfire all on one channel
check out the link in our description
and tell them two cents sent you thanks
to our patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron